maurice is with us maurice is in georgia
hi maurice welcome to the dave ramsey
show
hi dave you and uh dr delany thank you
for taking my call today
sure how can we help colin uh i'm a
federal employee dave
and um i've been uh not laid off but um
for 90 days we were sent home due to the
corona virus
and fortunately i am getting paid my
regular salary
um by being off the question i have for
you and dr deloney today
is um should i return back to work
i um give you a little history i'm a
military veteran
and um as i say i'm a federal employee
and i suffer from copd
and i'm at high risk due to you know
having these conditions from the
military and all
and i do um receive a uh military uh
disability check as well
through the va and uh i'm debt-free
uh other than my home i owe
approximately twelve thousand dollars
left on my home
um and i just wanna
kind of get a question about should i
returned to finish paying off my home
there uh
is it okay if i seek employment or other
elsewhere
um i'm just uh from
really concerned because of my
conditions and everything
i'm not comfortable with going back and
returning to work
um somewhat fearful uh fearful
i admit and
just need some guidance on
helping making that decision well your
fear is logical
with copd this is i mean there's
you're you're definitely an at-risk
person with the information that we
lay people all have uh from the medical
community uh
so your fears is logical uh
then if i'm in your shoes the thing i'm
gonna do is continue to gather
information
um and not from google or the media but
uh to put some wise choices in my life
and uh if i have a fear that is
illogical that's a spiritual and
emotional thing if i have
a fear that's logical i have to work
through the logic
and so do you have a personal physician
that you could consult with that could
give you advice and say uh maurice
really in your situation this is okay
or no don't go back over there
i do dave uh actually i am seen at the
local va facility in my area and i'm
honored position kid i've been under
physician care for quite some time since
um
uh returning from the different wars
from my life in afghanistan
and um i have been advised um of course
my mental condition and i do know
my bike line and pass with um dealing
with this
and if not to the point where it's
severe that i haven't they advise but he
advised you not to go back to work
well he didn't advise me um he's kind of
leaving it open
for me and that he don't exactly
know the type of work that i do i do
clear for work but yet i'm on an
industrial flight line
so i do come in contact with um
different mechanics
different um people uh contract people
um as well i think you need to give some
detail to him so that he can give you
some guidance you gotta be real direct
with your doctor
um and this is going on all over the
country where everyone's just nervous to
make a call and you've got to
get a doctor and you've got to put them
point blank and say i'm asking you for
your professional opinion
and they're probably going to give you
either a super conservative
if you're going to pin them down they're
going to say well then we're going to
recommend you stay home
but you got to get a medical doctor's
opinion and i
this is something that i've worked with
veterans
for my whole career when you are a
combat veteran like you are number one
thank you for what you do
thank you for what you did and thank you
for who you are number two
you've got a picture of trauma you've
got a picture of
quote unquote what could happen that
most of us
roaming around the streets don't have
and so your fear alarms are louder than
mine
your understanding of risk is greater
than mine and so i want
you to listen to that but also get a
group of people like dave said in your
life that you trust
that can give you facts give you data
that know you
and they can help you move on um you've
got no obligation to put yourself in a
situation you're going to get hurt and
sick and scared because you're trying to
be tough
or because you want to avoid a hard
conversation with the doctor okay i want
to high five you and say
go put your physician on notice that you
need answers and you need support
and by the way i would keep the
conversation rolling like uh
you know should i go back here's the
environment here's the type of people
i'm going to be in contact with here's
the process
is that going to cause me a super high
risk
um now not a minor risk we all take them
you're going to take a minor risk when
you get the car and drive over there
so we all have we all take risks but
what you've got to do is
is the is the risk a reasonable
risk that a wise person would do in this
situation
and then if he says no that job right
there you don't need to do that anymore
then you ask him the next question is
what job can i do
uh because i am not going to get you
give you a recommendation just as your
friend
that says never come out of your home
again nope
that would be a bad recommendation uh
and
that that's you know i don't think
that's good i don't think that's
reasonable in this situation so again
but i i you know if it was me that's
exactly how i would handle it i would
talk to the doc and go okay
if i don't need to do that because
there's too much contact there
and you know and because of my issue my
copd i got this is a major issue it
could be it could kill me
uh okay i get that so what kind of
situations can i be in
and you know then you work it from there
but the question behind that question
dave that i want to make sure
all the listeners are hearing is it will
be weird
going back to work because it's weird
coming in here
it will be give yourself permission to
be uncomfortable that's just the way
it's going to be because we've been told
that every cough and sneeze
and weird doorknob is going to kill us
and it might that's the thing so
expect it to be weird expect to have
some nerves
find some people in your community you
can talk to about it and don't beat
yourself up over being uncomfortable
going back into the workforce
and then you got to make this fact
informed decisions yeah exactly we
reopened our office
exactly the same way the governor's
opened the state of tennessee and so
um we've had a thousand people working
from home for five weeks
and we said you know uh we could go
monday's voluntary this last monday is
we're reopening and unless you have an
issue like he's got then
you need to be here and some of the
folks in here in the last monday if you
walked around the floors kind of had
that
look that deer in the headlights look
like looking around looking like
something are you going to kill me you
going to kill me right a little bit of
that
and uh but now you know here we are
three or four days later
and it's it's back to normal people are
are treating each other
you know with with uh you know they
don't have that look
and some people have masks and they're
being treated right yeah some people
don't and they're being treated well so
it's everybody honoring each other and
um yeah but the
the the the thing is it is i was in the
building the whole time because we've
been doing the thing here it was empty
it was eerie
this huge huge office building holds a
thousand people there's nobody in here
but about 20 of us
that was weird for several weeks and
then we had a few more in here and then
we had you know then we're all back here
but you're right there's a there's a
process that you go through there's kind
of a thawing out
of your heart uh your heart's like
frozen in these situations or something
like that i don't know what the metaphor
is but
that um some people are putting denim on
their body for the first time in the
last they've just had sweatpants and uh
pajama bottoms and that feels weird too
people putting on pants
for the first time five weeks and weeks
man i'm grateful for you maurice thanks
for calling me yeah thank you for
thank you for what you do and your fear
is not illogical sir
uh but you can work through even a
logical fear
and minimize the risk and you know put
some boundaries up and say okay
under these circumstances this is a good
idea and if you have copd you're not a
wimp for staying home amen
amen no good for you you are a wimp
first
you you got a wimp but it's not going to
be good for you to stay home
and never do anything the rest of your
life on that basis bad move too
that's not wisdom so there's this thing
where we figure out what are the
parameters by which we can go forward
whether it's that job or another job